เฮ
[Música]
Boa noite, agora vocês me ouvem? Edivan,
Beta Gaia,
sejam bem-vindos.
Por favor, me confirmem se vocês me
ouvem agora, porque eu inventei de
trocar o microfone no meio da live, não
deu certo.
Vocês estão me ouvindo? Opa, agora se
Bem, sejam muito bem-vindos para mais
uma live. Temos bastante perguntas hoje,
então vamos começar aqui.
Deixa eu acertar a apresentação primeiro
e tem só um instantezinho aqui.
Pronto.
Colocar o link do momento.
Muito baixo o som.
Alguém mais tá anotando o som baixo?
Ah, de novo. Como errado. Melhorou o som
agora.
OK. O som tá normal agora, né? Porque
tava pegando outro microfone mesmo.
Legal. Vamos continuar aqui então.
Então, sejam muito bem-vindos. Vamos
começar mais uma live com as perguntas.
É, nossa, hoje tá zicado o negócio aqui.
Cadê a a janela?
Ah, tá aqui. Pronto.
Muito bem, pessoal. Vamos lá. Primeira
pergunta. Toda pessoa
que tem dificuldade em ganhar peso é
adrenégica poderia fazer uma live ou
explicar melhor o significado de
adrenégico.
Bem, Vilma, eu não sei bem se
você,
melhor dizendo, onde você viu essa
história de Adrenico, tá? Eu preciso
saber a fonte de onde você tirou essa
informação.
Ah, então é Denise Blue que tá falando
aí com a identidade secreta de Betaga
Gaia. Tá certo.
Bem, Andrenégico não é exatamente um
tipo de pessoa, é um termo que descreve
sistema corporal que libera ou que
responde adrenalina ou noradrenalina.
Dito isso,
pessoas que têm dificuldade em ganhar
peso frequentemente possuem uma
atividade adrenégica mais acentuada,
são pessoas mais elétricas, mais
agitadas, né? Não sei se é isso, você
quer dizer quadrenégérgico, mas pode ser
que seja isso. Então, significa que
esses receptores betaadrenégicos estão
mais ativos, né? Estando mais ativos,
eles podem favorecer a lipólice, que é a
quebra de gordura. Então, o sistema
nervosimpático tá mais ligado, mais
acelerado e acelerando o metabolismo,
dificultando o ganho de peso. Então,
temos estudos mostrando que o receptor
beta3 adrenégico, ele tem papel
fundamental na regulação do peso
corporal, influenciando tanto o gasto
energético quanto a mobilização de
gordura.
Podemos pensar numa live a respeito
desse assunto, né?
Bom, pro próximo, próxima pergunta.
Fiz um exame recentemente. Meu
egfr, né, que é a taxa de filtração
glomerolar estimada, deu 62.
Porém, notei que ele vem caindo
comparado a outros exames. Em 2023 tava
103, em 2024 97.
Esse ano eu fiz um exame em abril e deu
68 e esse mês 62.
Minha médica não falou nada sobre isso.
O resto parece tá normal.
Tirando vitamina D3, que está um pouco
aumentada e creatinina.
Porém, eu tomo creatina.
Devo me preocupar com esse padrão. Olha,
na minha experiência
não tá, porque essa taxa de filtração
gromero lá estimada, ela é muito falha.
A maioria dos pacientes que passam com
bigo tem essa taxa reduzida,
mas tem que ficar de olho, tá?
A creatina, ela faz subir a creatinina
de maneira artificial. Então, no seu
caso, eu sugiro que você utilize um
outro marcador que é a cistatina C.
Cistatina C. Vou escrever aqui para
vocês, tá?
Tá? Então esse é o outro marcador que
substitui a creatinina para quem tá
tomando creatina.
Então seria esse exame que eu sugiro que
você converse com a médica, tá? Também
interessante, caso você esteja com
pressão alta,
faça uma avaliação de albuminúria, ou
seja, albumina na urina de 24 horas e a
relação albumina creatinina na urina.
Esse é um indicador mais importante que
determina se você realmente tem doença
renal crônica ou não.
Porque esse tal de EGFR, né, que é a
taxa de filtração glomerolar estimada,
ele é muito falho, tá?
Fique de olho na sua pressão arterial.
Fique de olho na glicose de jejum, na
insulina de jejum,
no ácido úrico, tá? Tudo isso tem que
ficar de olho.
Vamos pra próxima. Aqui só tem pergunta
gigante agora, ó.
Minha vitamina D em abril desse ano
estava 336 nanomoles, que corresponde,
tem que fazer a conversão aqui.
Ah, parei com a suplementação e esse mês
medi novamente, está em 123. Aqui no
Canadá é muito complicado fazer exame de
vitamina D rotineiramente sem uma causa
patológica.
Escuto muitos médicos falando sobre as
10.000 unidades por dia como uma dose
segura. Inclusive Dr. Berg, Eric Berg é
muito bom. material dele e até mesmo um
reumatologista que consultei alguns anos
atrás, porém fiquei com receio de
experimentar depois que os meus níveis
chegaram a 336 nanomes por litro. Tenho
doença autoimune e gostarei de manter
níveis adequados.
Além do que na América do Norte não
temos muita exposição ao Sol, sem
dúvida. Ainda mais no Canadá. O senhor
concorda com essa dose 10.000? Ui?
Depende. Na maioria dos casos essa dose
vai bem, mas tem que monitorar o sangue
sim.
Tá?
Para quem tem doença autoimune, o ideal,
já que você tá usando nanomoles por
litro, é manter entre 150 e 200,
não 300, tá? 300 realmente tá muito
alto.
Geralmente 10.000 1000 por dia é seguro,
mas tem que monitorar no sangue.
E é muito importante também, como já
falei em vários vídeos, manter a
vitamina D junto com a K2 e o magnésio.
O pico, você chegou a 336 nanomoles por
litro, geralmente não dá toxicidade se
você tiver esses níveis que não ficaram
mantidos por muito tempo.
E a doença autoimune. Você sabe que quem
faz esse protocolo Coimbra coloca a
vitamina D muito alto. Se fizer a dieta
baixa em cálcio é seguro. OK.
Então mantém a vitamina D 10.000 por
dia, mantém a K2, mantém o magnésio
e dose a vitamina D após 3 meses para
ver se ela tá nessa faixa entre 150 e
200 nanomes por litro que vai
corresponder a 60 ng por ml que a medida
que a gente usa mais no Brasil.
Se ficar abaixo de 150 nanomoles por
litro, você pode aumentar a sua vitamina
D temporariamente para 12 ou 15.000 por
dia, tá?
E só faça o protocolo de megadoses do
Coimbra se você tiver um médico
acompanhando
o seu caso, tá?
Vi o vídeo sobremina, só achei produto
internacional. Qual você indica? Eu
coloquei no vídeo, você prestou atenção
no vídeo? Eu falei as marcas lá,
olha o vídeo de novo, tá? Mas você
encontra marcas como Neurogan,
você pode mandar manipular também.
No caso, deixa eu abrir até o
Me dê só um instante aqui que eu tenho
as marcas do vídeo aqui que eu coloquei.
Cara, não tô achando texto aqui.
Tá, eu vou acabar perdendo tempo aqui.
Eu tenho outras perguntas para
responder, mas olha o vídeo de novo que
tá lá. as marcas. Tá bom, vou passar pra
próxima pergunta.
Ué.
Ah, tá aqui.
Quando se fala em câncer de mama,
hormônio dependente, se refere a
hormônio sintético.
Exemplo premarim é ou hormônio
bioidêntico isomolecular. Não, quando a
os médicos ginecologistas usam esse
termo, estão se referindo a qualquer
hormônio, tá? Eles não estão se
referindo a se é isomolecular ou não.
Então se refere a capacidade de qualquer
hormônio estrogênico ou progestagênico
de estimular o crescimento de células
tumorais.
Então, dentre os cânceres de mama,
aproximadamente 70 a 80% dos cânceres de
mama são classificados como
hormôniodependentes.
O que significa que as células têm
receptores para estrogênio ou
progesterona. e cresce em resposta a
esses hormônios. Então, mesmo que seja
vidente coisa molecular, se a pessoa
tiver diagnóstico câncer de mama, tem
que interromper imediatamente o uso
desses hormônios.
Agora, tem estudos que mostram que
hormônios sintéticos apresentam maiores
riscos de proliferação celular mamária e
maior aumento de densidade mamária
quando comparado os biidênticos. Mas
isso não muda o fato que tem que
suspender no caso do diagnóstico.
Então, na verdade, o biidêntico não é
totalmente isento de risco, tá? Se a
mulher que tiver usando o bioidêntico ou
isomolecular esteja inflamada, um detox
ruim,
pode acontecer do metabolismo do
estrogênio não tá bom e formar
metabólicos cancerígenos, tá?
Sempre
o bioidêntico isomlecular vai ser melhor
do que o artificial para reposição
hormonal. Mas novamente, se tiver
diagnóstico câncer de mama, tem que ser
imediatamente suspenso.
Como fazer detox dos nanoplásticos? Tá
aí a pergunta de 1 milhão dólares.
Não tem métodos atuais,
que eu saiba não, já pesquisei isso
várias vezes,
que sejam clinicamente validados para
remover microplásticos. Então isso até o
momento não tem solução, tá? Nem
microplásticos, nem nanoplásticos.
Tem um procedimento que tá circulando aí
nas redes sociais,
eh, que é o tal do Clari by Marker, que
é um procedimento baseado em plasma fée,
não tem ainda comprovação científica
sólida que seja capaz de eliminar
nanoplásticos. Então, a plasma féence é
um procedimento bem complexo, bem caro e
não tem comprovação que vai tirar os
micro ou nanoplásticos.
Então, a única coisa que nós podemos
fazer é tentar diminuir o plástico na
vida da gente.
Se tiver condição de comprar um bom
filtro com água de osmose reversa, né,
que transforme a água em água quase que
destilada por osmose reversa ou
destilação,
seria a solução mais viável aí. Mas
teria que tá tomando água só dessa
fonte, né?
Doutor sempre
tem preocupação em manipular os
suplementos em cápsulas incolor, pois
não quero todo dia ficar tomando
corantes. E sim, é corretíssimo isso.
A farmácia diz ser corante natural
vegetal, porém eu tenho sensibilidade
com a maioria dos vegetais,
principalmente os icos lectinas. Estou
certa em evitar as cápsulas coloridas.
Sim, você tá certíssima. Não tem nenhuma
necessidade de tomar capas colorida,
pois às vezes consigo comprar pelo
Mercado Livre, mais barato, mas não
consigo escolher que seja em color. Faz
manipulado, tá? Não faz sentido você
usar com com cor, ainda mais se você é
sensível, tá?
A indústria aos poucos tá migrando para
corantes naturais. É o caso da
beterraba, urucum,
antocianinas.
Mas vai demorar alguns anos para isso
acontecer de maneira mais efetiva.
Mas no seu caso, se você sensível até os
naturais, peça sempre sem corante.
Melhor manipular do que ficar comprando
no Mercado Livre nesse caso, ou
comprando na internet.
Doutor Alant, todas as lives sobre as
dúvidas são muito importantes para nós
que apreciamos. A questão é que todas
ficam no canal, mas sem um índice na
capa. Gente, eu já conversei com vocês
sobre isso,
tá?
A questão é, algum de vocês poderia
assumir essa questão? É só ir lá no
vídeo. O vídeo tem a transcrição da
minha voz. Existe hoje as que você
consegue usar IA para fazer o resumo,
para fazer esse índice. Eu cheguei a
fazer isso daí ano passado, mas tava
tomando muito tempo, tá? E eu decidi que
não é não vale a pena eu usar meu tempo
para isso, tá? Eu já expliquei isso para
vocês, ninguém assumiu essa função, tá?
Então eu simplesmente gastei muito tempo
para fazer essa parte aí de criar
índice, de fazer essa questão dos
resumos, tá? Então se vocês não vão
assumir essa situação, eu não vou
assumir, tá? OK? Deixar bem claro isso
daí.
E eu não tenho problema nenhum de estar
respondendo de novo perguntas que já
foram respondidas, tá bom? Não tem
problema nenhum.
Qual a sua opinião sobre o exame Scor C
para determinar a saúde das artérias? É
um exame muito importante,
é um exame que eu pesco com frequência.
Então é muito importante junto com a
cetilografia miocárdica, muitas vezes é
o exame que vai determinar se a pessoa
vai ter que fazer ou não o cateterismo
coronariano.
Agora eu não sigo isoladamente só esse
marcador, tá?
A calcificação das artérias é apenas a
ponta do iceberg. Então ele representa
aproximadamente 20% da carga total de
placa teroscleródtica.
O problema real são as placas, que são
as placas moles, não calcificadas, que
são estáveis e propensas à ruptura,
podem gerar trombose e entupimento.
E essa não aparece tão bem no scor de
cálcio.
E o scor de cálcio também não diz nada
sobre a qualidade, o tipo de partícula
ideal e circulante.
A minha recomendação é usar o score de
cálcio como ferramenta complementar e
não como protagonista da avaliação
cardiovascular, mas ela é importante em
vários casos, sim. Então é importante
fazer avaliações funcionais completas do
LDL total, LDL oxidado, se for possível,
a polipoproteína 1, a polipoproteína B,
LPA, homocisteína,
proteína Creativa, tá bom?
Isso tudo também é muito importante.
Minha mãe tem 69 anos e tremor nas mãos
quando toma café. Tento tirar a
estatina, mas a médica dela grita.
Pregnenolona, ajudou um pouco, mas está
proibido.
Mas pregnenolona para melhorar no
colesterol, você teve uma uma boa
experiência com isso? É interessante.
Quais opções para esse tipo de
tremedeira ou quais exames pedir para
fechar o diagnóstico?
Eu não entendi o que tem a ver o tremor
na mão com a estatina.
Tá meio estranha essa pergunta aqui.
Mas é muito simples, né? Se ela tem
tremor na mão quando toma café, tem que
parar de tomar café, né?
Então é bem claro isso daí, né? Se ela
tem sensibilidade a cafeína, ela teria
que eliminar o café da vida dela.
Agora, faça uma avaliação cardiológica
completa, né?
Então, para avaliar o trembor também
poderia estar pedindo exames de tireode,
TSH, T4 livre, vitaminas B12, vitamina
D, magnésio, cálcio.
Tem também um exame neurológico simples
que pode ser feito, que a gente pode
observar o tremor em repouso versus em
movimento,
ressonância magnética tomografia.
Poderia ser necessário se tivesse algum
tipo de suspeita de um tremor
parxoniano, tá? Mas tudo indica que é o
problema da cafeína.
Mas aí eu acho que você misturou duas
coisas aí, né? Por que que por que você
colocou estatina nessa história aí que
eu não entendi?
Mas se você quiser tirar a estatina, que
não tem nada a ver com tremor, você pode
estar pensando em dar para ela
exanicotinatinos
berberina,
seria uma opção
ômega3 com enzima que é 10,
tá? Não sei se eu entendi a a intenção
de misturar esses dois assuntos aqui,
né? Eu acho que você tá pensando que a
estatina que tá causando o tremor. Não,
mas você tá falando que é o é o café.
Então você mesmo tá dizendo que é o café
aqui, depois fala da estatina, né? Tá?
Então não entendi muito bem a lógica aí.
Se você tiver ao vivo, Víctor, a gente
pode conversar, tá bom?
Tenho mutação isolada H6D
heterozigoto no sangue. Tomo ácido R
alfa lipóico 100 mg em jejum
de forma contínua para evitar a
sobrecarga de ferro. Tem algum problema?
Aproveitando,
o feno grego tem em sua composição
ferro, pois eu tenho receio de
experimentar por esse motivo.
Bem, a mutação H63D
heterozigose isolada,
na grande maioria dos casos, não tem
essa sobrecarga de ferro clinicamente
significativa. Eu sei que é o gên
relacionado à hemocromatose,
mas nem sempre é o caso de tá acumulando
ferro, tá? Tem que ver o valor de
ferritina, ferro sérico, saturação de
transferrina antes de fazer qualquer
intervenção.
Com a mutação heterozigota,
100 mg de alfalipôico contínuo,
provavelmente não vai trazer o efeito
quelante que você espera pro ferro,
porque as doses eficazes para aquelação
de ferro com folico começam a partir de
300 mg por dia, pode chegar até 600 ou
mais.
Então, resumindo, o alfa lipoico tem
capacidade de eliminar essa de ferro,
mas nessa dosagem baixa e sem indicação
clara de sobrecarga pode não ser
necessário. Então, faça os testes de
ferro periodicamente. Se os valores
esverem normais, nós não precisaria eh
suplementação preventiva para esse fim.
E o feno grego,
ele tem sim ferro na composição, como
praticamente todas as sementes e
legumes.
Porém, tem que ver primeiro se você tem
ou não tem sobrecarga de ferro, tá? O
gene sozinho não é o suficiente.
Se você não tiver sobrecarga, não tem
razão para evitar
as sementes leguminosas.
A questão não é se a semente tem ferro
ou não, mas se você tá de fato
acumulando.
Bem, vamos pro próximo.
Dr. Alan, bom dia. Tenho duas perguntas
bem importantes para mim. Minha mãe aos
88 anos sofreu uma fratura em T10,
consolidou o conservador e acredito que
por conta disso ela tem uma
pseudoartrose
e portanto isso justificaria tanta dor.
Ela toma pouco remédio, na verdade hoje
ela tem 90. Gostaria de saber se indica
algum remédio que pudesse ajudá-la na
manutenção da dor.
Gente, eu não faz pergunta quilométrica.
Pode fazer mais de uma pergunta no mesmo
documento, tá?
Eh, dois, tenho 59 anos, estou fazendo
doutorado e estressada, engordando,
parece que meu cérebro só consegue
trabalhar quando como doce ou
carboidrato.
Comecei a usar contráve, que é
combinação tipo propriona comrixona, mas
ele causa muito enjoo e dor de cabeça e
tenho que ficar bem para poder
trabalhar, estudar e cuidar da minha
mãe. Teria alguma sugestão de
ansiolítico?
É anciolítico, né? Antianciolítico, não,
tá? Ou algo para conter o apetite no meu
caso.
Bem, primeiro vamos falar da sua mãe. Em
relação a à sua mãe, a pseudoartrose
idoso, realmente precisa de uma
abordagem conservadora e segura.
Primeiro, é muito importante investigar
os níveis de vitamina D, cálcio
ionizável e outros micronutrientes que
seriam essenciais paraa consolidação
óssea, pois deficiências nutricionais
são comuns nessa faixa etária e agravam
muito a dor. Então, pro controle
sintomático, além de analgésicos
convencionais, se necessário, eu sugiro
avaliar a terapia por ondas de choque
focalizadas, que é não invasiva e tem
mostrado resultados comparáveis à
cirurgia sem os riscos. E paralelamente,
otimize a alimentação eliminando o
glúten derivados do leite. E use-se
também
magnésio, ômega-3 e outros
anti-inflamatórios naturais, como
curcomina, como bozuélia.
em relação a você à dependência
carboidrato
é tipicamente um marcador de disfunção
metabólica e deficiências nutricionais.
O contráve, então ele tem sim esses
efeitos colaterais que você descreveu,
justamente porque forca um sistema que
já tá desequilibrado. Então a minha
sugestão é abandone essa abordagem e
faça uma reavaliação completa. Elimine
alimentos inflamatórios e vista em
refeições equilibradas com proteínas de
qualidade, gordura de qualidade.
considera experimentação cromo,
tirosina,
vitamina complexo B para regular
neurotransmissor eem ansiedade. Outra
coisa que você pode fazer é usar a
combinação da bupropriona com arexona e
com 5 KTP em doses mais baixas, tá? Em
vez de usar o contro
estresse, doutorado, faça meditação,
respiração profunda, exercício físico
consistente,
né? E faça um agendamento, uma consulta
com médico funcional.
Doutor, qual a relação entre a vitamina
B12 e o magnésio em termos de absorção?
Qual o magnésio tomar com a B12?
Então, não existe interação negativa
entre B12 e magnésio para absorção. Eles
não competem entre si, tá? são
absorvidos por mecanismos distintos no
trato digestório, então você pode sim
tomar junto. E o que realmente importa é
a qualidade da forma do magnésio e o
timing de administração. O magnésio
queelado e o dimalato são as formas mais
biodisponíveis
e bem absorvidas, diferente do cloreto
de magnésio que é mal absorvido e pode
causar diarreia.
Em relação aos horários, o melhor
horário magnésio à noite antes de dormir
ou em jejum pela manhã, nunca após
refeições
principais, porque prejudica a digestão.
A B12, por sua vez, ela depende do ácido
gásico, né, e do fator intrínseco para
ser absorvida. Portanto, se você está
tomando measol qualquer tipo de prazol,
bloqueador de próton, né, sua absorção
vai est comprometida. Nesse caso,
suplementação é mais importante. Você
pode usar sublingual, 500 a 1000 microg
e usar em torno de 400 mg de magnésio
elementar na forma de queelado de
malato, né, por exemplo.
OK.
Tenho observado aqui na minha cidade que
a cada 10 pessoas que morrem, dois é de
AVC, três de infarto e quatro de câncer.
Apenas uma para as outras.
causas. Os imunizantes têm alguma
relação com esses números.
Então, mas na verdade são as causas
principais de morte, né?
Essas doenças são as mais comuns que
levam à morte, tá? É muito difícil
saber. Teria que fazer o quê? uma
pesquisa, pegar os números antes, né,
dos imunizantes, comparar com os números
depois do imunizantes. Isso já foi
feito, por exemplo, Portugal e outros
países e foi visto que sim, aumentou a
mortalidade geral, não tem uma prova
cabal que seja os imunizantes, mas é uma
sugestão muito forte. No Brasil a
escolhambação reina, né? Então a gente
não tem esses dados aí tão bem
estabelecidos, tá?
Eu
acredito que tem relação com os
imunizantes, mas a gente não tem dados
confiáveis no Brasil. Essa que é a
resposta mais correta.
Pode acontecer de uma pessoa ter
resistência insulínica, mesmo com uma
insulina de 3,3.
É possível.
O que acontece é que muitas vezes essa
pessoa pode ter essa insulina baixa aí
porque ela ficou alguns dias sem comer
carboidrato
e pode ter feito o exame depois disso.
Então, o ideal é você usar um conjunto
de marcadores, por exemplo, R, que é uma
fórmula que calcula insulina e jejum
vezes a glicemia de jejum dividido por
405.
Isso aí é mais
acurado que só olhar o a insulina.
Existe pessoas, por exemplo, que têm
falência pancreática exócrina, né? O
pâncreas exócrino, tá? Desculpa, o
pâncreas endócrino tá falhando e ela
pode estar uma glicemia bem alta com
insulina baixa, porque o pâncreas já tá
falido, tá?
Então é importante fazer o Ioma e
verificar também frutosaminas,
hemoglobina agricada,
V triglicérides, VHDL também, que
geralmente quem tem estessulínca tem
triglicérides altos e HDL baixa.
A gente sempre tem que ver o contexto
metabólico completo, não poucos
marcadores isolados, tá?
É muito importante
para o tratamento da vesícula, qual é a
composição e doses recomendados para
túdica?
Bem, o údica é o ácido uso deóxicólico
e o túdica é o tauro úso deoxicólico.
Ok?
Como é que funciona o údica? Ele é um
ácido biliar natural. Ele funciona
dessaturando a bi litogênica. Ele
facilita a dissolução de cálculos de
colesterol. A dose recomendada de 5 a 10
mg por kg de peso corporal por dia, o
que geralmente corresponde a 300 a 600
mg de ários. 300 a 600 mg de ário.
O túdica, o tauro deoxicólico, é a forma
conjugada do údica com taurina. Isso vai
fazer o quê? vai potencializar
a ação hepatoprotetora e biliar,
permitindo melhor absorção e efetividade
com doses similares ajustadas.
A razão pela qual demora tanto para
fazer efeito está no fato de que após 3
meses de uso contínuo, o UDCA
atinge o equilíbrio dinâmico na
composição biliar e a dissolução efetiva
dos cálculos vai exigir no mínimo de 4 a
6 meses de tratamento.
Então por isso que tem que tomar um ano.
Isso daí
pode estender facilmente além dos 12
meses.
Então, por isso tem que tomar muito
tempo.
E geralmente esses dois vão funcionar
melhor para cálculos menores que 5 mm,
tá? Cálculos grandes geralmente não
funciona bem.
Boa noite. A coisa maquia 10 manipulada
tem a mesma qualidade das marcas
tradicionais.
Bem, a qualidade da coisa maquedis, ela
depende muito da farmácia escolhida e da
fonte da matéria prima.
Os medicamentos manipulados oferecem uma
vantagem significativa, porque você
consegue fazer de uma maneira
personalizada e sem aditivos necessárias
que eles colocam muitas vezes nos
produtos que eles vendem na internet.
Alguém, acho que foi a Maria Helena,
colocou aí no grupo, no WhatsApp, o Max
Souve, tá? Maxve é uma coisa que é 10
líquida que é muito boa, é um pouco
cara, mas ela é muito boa, tá?
Então, o fator crítico é a qualidade e a
pureza da biquinona, do biquinol que a
farmácia vai adquirir como matéria
prínima. Uma farmácia com manipulação
séria que trabalha com fornecedores
certificados,
como é o caso integritar, vai ter a os
laudos, né, dos dos fabricantes, dos
fornecedores
e vai ter então esse teste de qualidade
que vão garantir um produto de boa
qualidade, tá?
Tomar muito cuidado com falsificação e
adulteração. Acontece muito isso nos
marketplace da vida aí, especialmente no
Mercado Livre.
Cuidado com as farmácias que vendem
livremente sem receita, porque
geralmente são empresas picaretas aí que
ficam trocando um CNPJ toda hora e não
são pessoas ou empresas idôneas, tá bom?
Peça sempre certificado de análise se
tiver dúvida da farmácia.
Boa noite. O senhor pode falar sobre os
benefícios do dinolmetano pro cérebro?
O je ele não é um suplemento específico
para cérebro. Ele é um fitoquímico que é
retirado de vegetais crucíferas, né,
como brócolis e covlor. Ele atua mais na
saúde do estrogênio, metabolismo
hormonal. Ele modula receptoras de
estrogênio e ajuda a não formar os
metabólitos cancerígenos.
Então é a questão do equilíbrio
hormonal, detox hepático, redução de
inflamação sistêmica,
propriedades antioxidantes. Ele não é
bem um agente nootrópico pro cérebro,
tá? Os mais interessantes pro cérebro é
ômega-3 DHA, é o magnésio tronato,
tem vários outros, tá? Mas aí não é o
caso do DIN para isso especificamente.
Ele pode ter benefícios indiretos pro
cérebro através da redução da inflamação
sistêmica
e melhor equilíbrio hormonal, mas não é
uma coisa direta não, tá?
A dose do é de 100 a 200 mg por dia.
Então é muito bom, especialmente na
perimenopausa, né, no climatério, quando
a mulher tem desequilíbrio grande do
estrogênio.
Doutor, uso intenso de redes sociais
celular desde criança pode simular
sintomas de autismo e depressão,
ansiedade, TDH? Muito boa pergunta. Tá
sim, a literatura internacional mais
recente tá sendo bastante clara nesse
ponto. O uso intenso de telas e redes
sociais desde cedo pode gerar sintomas
que mimetizam perfeitalmente o autismo,
o TDH, depressão e ansiedade, né? Até
difícil de você definir se tá
mimetizando ou se de fato tá gerando
essas doenças.
Então, quando uma criança passa mais de
4 horas diárias em ambientes virtuais,
ela desenvolve deprivações socioafetivas
e sensó motoras também. Então, isso vai
resultar redução da tensão sustentada,
sono prejudicado pela exposição ao luz
azul, aumento de comportamentos
impulsivos, dificuldades na
autorregulação emocional,
desinteresse por interações presenciais
e atraso de linguagem. Aconteceu muito
isso durante a pandemia. Um estudo da
UFMG, né, Universidade Federal de Minas
Gerais mostrou que 72% das crianças
avaliadas apresentaram aumento da
depressão
associado ao uso de telas.
Enquanto a comparação constante com
padrões idealizados nas redes sociais
vai disparar, assim como acontece com os
adultos, ansiedade e segurança corporal.
Então fica bem difícil saber se tá
imitando mesmo ou se não tá gerando
essas doenças, né?
Mas e acredita-se, se você deixar a
criança afastada desses estímulos, vai
reverter, né?
Então, é por isso que nós estamos vendo
o crescimento explosivo de telas,
desculpa, explosivo de diagnósticos de
TDAH e autismo, justamente quando as
telas explodiram na infância.
Então, é de bom bom tom, é é praste, né?
Antes de rotular a criança, eliminar
completamente a exposição digital por um
período e observar se os sintomas
realmente persistem.
Magnésio, glicina
para intestino preguiçoso deve ser
ingerido com alimentação. Registro aqui
uma imensa admiração e gratidão.
Obrigado pelas palavras, tá?
Pois na época da pandemia o doutor fez
toda a diferença.
Então, eh, o magnésio, glicina, o
bisglicinato, ele deve ser geralmente
tomado longe de refeição. Ele não é o
melhor magnésio para soltar intestino.
vai ser o cloreto de magnésio, óxido de
magnésio ou mesmo
o citrato de magnésio.
Então, se você tá pensando em melhorar o
intestino, use uma um desses daí, tá?
Porque o magnésio bisoglicinato ele não
é para ter efeito laxativo.
Importante investigar a causa raiz do
seu intestino lento, que pode ser falta
de fibra, falta de água, pode ser
alimentação inflamatória, né? Então é
importante eh você pode usar assim o
citrato de magnésio para ajudar o
intestino funcionar, mas faça
investigação paralelo, tá?
Como fazer para baixar o colesterol
total 235 mg por m por dclil de forma
eficiente e rápida?
Paciente feminino 57 anos.
Bem, primeiro que não é bem só olhar o
colesterol total, tem que verl,
colesterol, HDL, triglicérides, tem que
olhar a pro A, a pro B, tem que ver
através dessas contas que a gente faz,
que a conta entre HDL e trigérides para
saber se o LDL em si ele tá tendendo a
oxidar ou não, se possível até medir o
LDL oxidado, tá bom?
Na verdade, o problema não é o LDL como
um todo, mas o LDL oxidado, que são os
os LDL de partícula pequena e densa,
como já expliquei em vários vídeos lá no
canal aberto.
Então, tente fazer todos esses exames
para chegar a uma conclusão, tá? E
apresentar pro médico que entende desse
tipo de assunto.
Outra coisa, tem que tá olhando também o
LPA, tá? A polipoproteína A1 e o LPA
também são importantes.
Sugiro ativar as legendas
automáticas nas lives.
Ué,
como assim?
Não entendi não. Essa legenda automática
aí que eu saiba é do seu lado que você
tem que ativar, né, Lúcia?
Existe um recurso no Chrome que você
consegue ativar a legenda em tempo real,
tá? Agora, não é uma coisa para eu fazer
do meu lado, é uma coisa para você fazer
do seu lado. Aí que eu saiba, não existe
esse recurso de legenda ao vivo na live,
tá?
Pelo menos dentro do Streamyard não tem
esse recurso.
Nunca vi isso.
Mas aí você pesquisa aí dentro do Chrome
tem essa função aí em seu vídeo sobre a
SPM medidina para que ela tenha os
resultados lá falados. Qual que é a dose
diária? Por volta de 5 a 10 mg por dia,
tá?
Os estudos mostram 1,3,3,
né? Então a faixa dos estudos é 3 a 10,
mas eu recomendarei de 5 a 10 para
facilitar, tá bom?
Doutor Alan, para a curvatura congênita
do pênis existe tratamento? Sim, é
cirúrgico. Não, não cirúrgico não
conheço, tá? Porque o peroni tem
tratamento não cirúrgico.
Agora o pênis
curvo congênito não tem como tratar com
outras coisas.
Agora, a cirurgia não é obrigatória. Se
a curvatura não for grande, suficiente,
às vezes não precisa operar.
Quando a curvatura é inferior a 30º
e não prejudica a função sexual ou
penetração,
tem que fazer só uma observação. Precisa
fazer cirurgia.
Existe aí algumas adaptações, pode mudar
a posição sexual, entendeu?
Mas realmente não adianta eu te falar
que vai ter um suplemento que vai
resolver isso, que não vai, tá? Agora no
caso do pironia vitamina E em altas
doses na forma de tocotrieno na
cochicina ou potaba. Eh, mas no caso do
penecvo congênito, não.
Aí teria que fazer uma cirurgia.
Dodor, no FAP você recomenda durante o
período evitar masturbação.
Que que é FAP, meu?
Será que eu entendi o que que é FAP?
A masturbação com imaginação sensual de
forma viciante por anos pode, em algum
cenário, seja rico ou mental, fazer mal,
seja deve ser rico, né?
Bem, deixa eu olhar o que que é essa
essa
sigla aqui. Realmente eu não conheço. Me
dá só um instante.
Tá. É uma gir informal em inglês que
imita o som associado ao ato de
masturbação,
tá? Então tem o movimento no FAP que
promove o desafio de abstinência de
masturbação.
OK? Então acho que eu entendi aqui
bem, a masturbação em si não é
considerada um problema, a não ser que
seja compulsiva, tá? Essa pessoa tem
vício mesmo. Tem algumas pessoas que não
conseguem mais estimular sem ser através
de erotização pela internet, pornografia
e masturbação. Se for esse o caso, aí
tem que se afastar desse tipo de
material e fazer um tratamento
neuropsiquiátrico, além de
acompanhamento psicológico.
Existe um fenômeno de dessensibilização
dos receptores de prazer e
neuroplastidade negativa no cérebro para
pessoas viciadas em masturbação.
Então esse noapou
aí deve ser o noap qu dizer que é
justamente esse movimento de não ficar
se estimulando com esse tipo de material
que é totalmente necessário quando a
pessoa tem esse problema, tem
assistência e vício. OK?
Tem estudos mostrando que um período de
abstinência de 30 a 90 dias pode
restaurar a sensibilidade neurológica
e melhorar essa situação do que está se
referindo aí. Tá bom?
Meu marido e eu somos ovola
pescatarianos.
Eh, o senhor recomendaria aminoácidos
complementares à alimentação?
Não, na verdade não, porque se você come
ovo, se você ingere derivado do leite e
peixe,
não vejo porque suplementar com mais
proteína, não, tá? Já teria suficiente
nessas três fontes.
Essas três fontes já teriam proteínas
biologicamente completas para todos os
aminoácidos essenciais.
Agora tem que só ficar prestando atenção
se o consumo de pescado for adequado,
duas a três porções por dia.
Agora, a questão do laticínio, que é
problemático, tá? Eu recomendo que vocês
não utilizem o laticínio normal e sim o
laticínio com casína do
então não há necessidade de
experimentação de aminoácidos.
Agora o que poderia ver, na verdade é a
vitamina B12, que é muito mais rica na
carne vermelha, tá? Tem gente que fica
com deficiência de B12 de não comer a
carne vermelha.
Dá uma olhada também no zinco, na
vitamina D de dado. Pode ser necessário
repor essas coisas aí.
E pensa no peixe gordo que é mais
saudável, é mais eh nutritivo que o
peixe que não é gordo, tá?
Uma criança até os 10 anos tinha
socialização, ainda que não muito mais
tinha socialização. Quando era bebê, ria
normal, brincava, interagia. Tudo que é
um bebê normal faz pode ser autismo.
Sim, tem algumas crianças que
desenvolvem o autismo depois começam
normal em desenvolvimento
e depois pode desenvolver o autismo, tá?
Depois dos 2 anos de idade, por exemplo.
Mas aí você falou que até os 10 anos,
né?
Aí já é mais complicado. Eu nunca vi
nenhum caso que começou autismo com 10
anos. Com 2 anos acontece.
Provavelmente essa criança não tem
transtorno espectro autista ou ela não
foi diagnosticada
na infância mais
precoce, digamos assim. Então pode ter
sido uma falha de diagnóstico, tá? Mas
assim, de ela ter sido normal e virou
autista com 10 anos é muito improvável
que o autismo geralmente ou ele começa
desde primeiros meses de vida ou ele tem
essa forma de autismo que vem depois,
mas geralmente com 2 anos de idade.
Aí tem que rever o passado, se de fato
ele já não tinha
ou ela ou ele, né? Atráso de fala, baixa
reatividade a sons,
demorou para falar, comportamento
repetitivo, restritivo, já no primeiro
ano de vida, pode ser que já tinha isso
daí e não foi diagnosticado, tá?
Mas existe outro desafio de
desenvolvimento. Tem tem, por exemplo,
né, quem trabalha com crianças sabe que
não é só TEIA e TDH, tem outros desafios
de desenvolvimento, né?
Tem um déficit eh de atenção, tem
questões de processamento sensorial, tá
bom? Tem o TDL,
então tem que tá vendo isso daí com
especialista nessa área.
O combo da energia toma 400 mg de
cozima, que é 10, além de outros ativos.
Pergunto, qual a melhor forma de tomar
os 400 mg de cozima, que é 10 todos de
manhã após o café ou 200 mg no café e os
outros 200 mg no almoço? É melhor
dividir. Se você prefere dividir, é
interessante, tá?
Lembrar que tem que tomar coisa de
maquedés com outras gorduras porque ela
é liposolúvel.
Então o ideal é você dividir em duas
doses, tá?
Aí você vai maximizar
a biodisponibilidade,
evita a a o desperdício do do
suplemento.
Apesar do combo da energia, noto que a
minha energia oscila muito. Então, eh,
muitas vezes só com eximed não resolve.
Tem que usar o pqq, tem que usar a
elicarnitina, tem que usar a creatina,
tem que usar derribose, tem que usar o
magnésio, tá? Não é só com enzima Q10,
não, tá? Eu geralmente eu nun geralmente
não, eu nunca passo só com enzima Q10
isolada. Eu uso esses outros ativos
juntos para quem tem queixa de energia.
E tem que investigar, né, se você não tá
com problema de hormônio tirodiano,
se você não tá com problema de cortisol,
tá?
Deficiências nutricionais. Às vezes
falta de ferro deixa a pessoa cansada.
Falta de cobre, falta de B12, falta de
magnésio, vitamina D.
Veja se o sono tá adequado, porque falta
de sono também leva essa queda de
energia, tá bom?
Veja se não tá com algum tipo de
inflamação sistêmica que pode estar
baixando seus níveis de energia.
Tudo isso é importante, tá?
Quais os melhores suplementos para
proteger o fígado, o estômago durante a
quimioterapia?
Ah, seria principalmente os tocenóis
do rucum,
seria
também
a crimarina,
seria importante, seria o ácido
alfalipoico.
Esses três seriam os principais, tá?
para proteger. Agora em relação a
estômago,
porque a quimioterapia oral é isso,
porque geralmente não pega tanto no
estômago a quimioterapia, ele pega mais
no fígado, né?
Mas pro estômago seria, por exemplo,
aloe vera, seria zincarnosina,
seria também espinheira santa. Tá,
doutor, dá para realizar um exame de
mana mauá seguro? Que que é isso?
Que que é isso? Não entendi. Manama,
não entendi não.
Existe uma outra sonografia com algum
nome específico.
Um profissional me informou que o
ultrassom só mostraria cálculos maiores
que 5 mm.
Ou seja, ah, deve ser mografia, né? Ou
seja, não detectaria nódulos mamários
menores. Então
não, não existe mamografia sem radiação.
Aí seria o caso de fazer uma
ressonância, se tiver indicação, tá?
Ressonância de mama ou uma termografia
de mama. Só que o problema da
termografia é que ele não é tão
específico para câncer de mama, mas pode
dar uma suspeita.
Tá bom? Então, seria ou uma temografia
ou uma ressonância de mama.
Existe alguma deficiência vitamínica que
pode levar alguém ter depressão
constante? Sim, várias. Deficiência de
magnésio, não é vitamina, mas pode
levar. Deficiência de zinco, pode levar
deficiência de cobre, pode levar
deficiência B12, pode levar deficiência
de B2, pode levar deficiência de B6,
pode levar, tá? Então é, tem vários
nutrientes aí que pode levar a
depressão, tá? É bem comum, inclusive.
Ah, Edson, não tem que saiba, tá?
Não tem que saiba para ajudar a plaqueta
baixa. É um grande desafio inclusive
isso daqui.
Bem, deixa eu
Pronto. Deixa eu colocar de volta aqui
no
Bem. Vamos só voltar uma pergunta aqui.
Eh, da, eu não sei agora, não lembro
mais quem que fez a pergunta. Eu vou
tentar ver uma automação, pessoal, para
criar esse índice no nas lives, tá? Mas
realmente eu fico um pouco chateado que
ninguém tem assumido essa essa função.
Eu não vou prometer para vocês, mas eu
vou tentar eh ver se uma automação
resolve esse problema, tá?
Tratamento para hemorroida que não fosse
cirúrgico. Será que a Dra. A Paula já
respondeu. Essa daqui seria basicamente
deosmin, né, que é o da Flon 500, que
seria espiridina com
diosmina, tá bom? Para hemorroide. E tem
a castanha da Índia também
na menopausa não tem uma relação direta
com o envelhecimento acelerado não, viu,
Fabiane? Não fique preocupada porque não
é bem assim, não.
Sim, é possível fazer essas
suplementações para quem tem apenas um
rim.
Isso é comum para as pessoas que ficam
mais estressadas no final da tarde.
Fabiane,
é verdade. Eu não tenho o que fazer
comanoplástico em termo de detox, não
tá? Ana Paula dando a sua opinião sobre
as cápsulas sem corantes.
Deitosa, depende se tem corante ou não,
tá? Ô Maria Helena,
Ana Paula respondeu aqui, ó.
Dei uma lida aí,
Dra. Ana Paula falando sobre score de
cálcio da anomografia.
respondendo sobre tremor.
É, ela lembrou aqui da sarcopenia, que
pode ser uma causa de tremor.
Even 90 mg por m. Tem outros tratamentos
em boro, silício, eh reposição hormonal
sensata,
vitamina D, vitamina K2, magnésio,
vitamina A, proteína, musculação, tudo
isso vai ajudar na osteoporose. Demora
para fazer efeito,
mas tem efeito sim.
Aí ó, a Marielana colocou aqui também o
Maxolve, que é uma coz de boa qualidade,
ótima qualidade, só meio caro.
Ah,
eu vi numa live com o Dr. Alexandre
sobre dieta carnívora, viu? O quê?
Não peguei o que você falou antes.
Ah, continuando sobre pessoas adrenicas.
Tá, entendi.
Para adultos, 8 horas de tela são
seguras? Depende, né?
Mas acho que geralmente pode-se dizer
que sim.
Olha, Edson, eu recomendo sempre colocar
as perguntas no documento, tá? Eu não
garanto nas lives responder as perguntas
que aparecem aqui, porque às vezes tem
muita pergunta no documento e não dá
tempo, tá? Eu tô passando rápido aqui
nas perguntas ao vivo.
Que pena. Estão indisponíveis? O que que
tá indisponível?
Não entendi.
Boa noite.
Se eu conheço esse talopran, conheço.
Antidepressivo.
É um antidepressivo que em metade das
pessoas vai fazer efeito, na outra
metade não faz efeito e tem vários
efeitos colaterais, tá? Então eu acho
que
tem que
analisar caso a caso. Se o psiquiatra
passou o estaloprã,
se em um mês ele não tiver um bom
resultado, tiver tendo muito efeito
colateral, que pode ser dor de cabeça,
sensação de cabeça pesada, náusea,
distúbio de sono, é melhor suspender,
tá?
É verdade. Isso, é verdade. Você tá
falando aí do autismo TDH, né?
Isso é verdade.
Dis que já respondi.
Uai, eh, alguém estudar como é que faz a
questão do pegar as transcrições do dos
vídeos e colocar um do um comentário com
os pontos do vídeo que tem a os
assuntos, entendeu? Mas acho que não tem
ninguém no grupo que tem facilidade com
informática. Parece ou cuia
ou se tem facilidade, tá quietinho.
Ã,
chá de folha de mamoeiro fez as
plaquetas. Eu já falei isso em vídeos,
tá? Mas isso daí é uma situação
específica para dengue, tá? Não é para
todos os casos de plaqueta baixa, não.
Ah, existe nos seus arquivos no canal
protocolo referente à resistência sula?
Tem, tem sim.
Bem, pessoal, vou parar aqui a live, tá?
Temos mais de uma hora de duração.
Obrigado pela participação de vocês. De
novo, eu vou dar uma estudada nessa
questão aí da dos índices das lives, tá?
Eu tava fazendo uma época, mas tava
tomando muito tempo, tava me
desgastando. É uma coisa, era uma coisa
muito monótona para fazer e tava tomando
muito tempo. Se eu conseguir criar uma
automação para isso, não prometo. Eu vou
tentar. Um abraço para vocês. Até a
próxima.
كده